abdelaziz bouteflika 1999-2000 19 20 ans
à la tête de l'algérie en quatre mandats
il a eu à faire à quatre présidents
français avec un thème au coeur des
échanges le passé colonial entre les
deux pays ont fait le bilan calmement
deux mois après son élection bouteflika
ouvre les bras ses homologues français
les bras et le coeur d'un corps immense
heymans immense et qui se contenir toute
la france il comptait bien en tant mieux
mon ami le président chirac
les en date que des françaises le passé
colonial entre les deux pays n'est pas
oublié mais entre chirac et bouteflika
c'est le début d'une coopération votre
visite d'état à paris marque une
nouvelle date dans l'histoire si forte
et si singulière de notre relation à
paris comme à alger un demi-siècle après
la guerre d'algérie un nouveau chapitre
s'ouvre le chapitre de la confiance de
l'astien du respect mutuel de l'amitié
et de la solidarité en 2004 dans le très
confidentiel fort de brégançon jacques
chirac annonce la signature prochaine en
traité d'amitié entre les deux pays
traiter que son successeur va laisser de
côté 2007 nicolas sarkozy est élu
président et avec l'algérie disons que
ça se refroidit je viens ici ni pour
blesser ni pour m'excuser quelques mois
plus tard
autre visite en algérie et autre preuve
de frilosité face à nicolas sarkozy le
président bouteflika parle en arabe
fait rare vous savez bien monsieur le
président l'amitié est légitime que je
vous porte de même que l'intérêt que je
ne cesse d'accorder au développement des
relations entre nos deux pays
5 milliards de dollars de contrats sont
tout de même signé et fin 2007 nicolas
sarkozy cède quelques mots dans le sens
des attentes des algériens
le système colonial a été profondément
injuste des crimes terribles ont été
commis tout au long d'une guerre
d'indépendance qui a fait d'innombrables
victimes 2012 françois hollande est élu
président ait choisi l'algérie pour sa
première visite d'état
ce voyage était nécessaire comme un air
de déjà vu quand ils déambulent côté de
bouteflika dans les rues d'alger
hollande sur les traces de chirac qui à
son tour poursuit le processus de
repentance
l'algérie a été soumise à un système
profondément injuste et brutale en 2010
est celui qui lui succédera emmanuel
macron va encore plus loin
pendant la campagne la colonisation fait
partie de l'histoire française c'est un
crime c'est un crime contre l'humanité
depuis que le peuple algérien s'est levé
contre un cinquième mandat de bouteflika
le président français s'est fait plutôt
discret jusqu'à l' annonce de son débat
qu'emmanuel macron a tenu à saluer
[Musique]